tu es Harvey, peu importe les mensonges que tu
te dis tu as fait ça aujourd'hui, Lady
Justice regarde un super prédateur
tu pensais pouvoir me terroriser ainsi que
les autres pour les faire taire tu avais tort nous sommes
ressuscités de tes cendres nous nous levons ensemble
[Musique]
une nouvelle  jour parce qu'Harvey Weinstein a
finalement été tenu responsable des crimes qu'il a
commis, les femmes qui se sont manifestées
courageusement et ce grand risque a fait en sorte que cela se
produise.
Weinstein est un prédateur sexuel en série vicieux
[Musique]
les femmes essayaient d'en parler pendant
des décennies, elles essayaient de parler  à
ce sujet et raconter l'histoire, ils
ne pouvaient pas le faire, vous savez, parce que tout le monde
avait peur, donc je pense que ce niveau de
pouvoir et de peur qu'il semble être capable
de la générer pour que ce plan puisse aller
[Musique]
à 21 ans, j'ai été violée par Harvey Weinstein, il
prétend que c'était consensuel, son avocat
prétend que Weinstein n'est pas à blâmer parce qu'il
n'a pas inventé le canapé de casting et
aussi parce que et c'est une citation directe
si une femme a des relations sexuelles pour l'aider dans sa
carrière à Hollywood, cela  ce n'est pas un viol,
il était extrêmement persistant et
physiquement accablant,
il s'est ensuite imposé oralement sur moi
pendant que j'avais mes règles, il a même
retiré mon tampon, j'étais mortifié,
j'étais incrédule et dégoûté, elle a
témoigné que m.  Weinstein a posé sa
main sur sa poitrine
et a
également tenté de toucher sa
région vaginale, il s'est masturbé et
l'a éjaculé sur une serviette tombée sur le
sol
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand on pense à Weinstein, c'est la raison pour laquelle
beaucoup ne l'ont pas fait  se manifester, c'est parce qu'il
détruirait cela et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous entendons à maintes reprises que nous sommes
des plaignants, nous ne nous sommes pas manifestés,
surtout dans ce cas précis,
parfois la raison pour laquelle les femmes ne se
manifestent pas et parfois les hommes gardent cela à
l'esprit est  dommage
[Musique]
elle a dit que vous savez qu'elle l'était, vous
savez qu'elle a vécu la même chose que
tant d'autres femmes, à savoir être
invitée dans sa chambre d'hôtel sous le
prétexte d'une sorte de
réunion professionnelle et lui demander de
lui donner un  massage, vous savez, en quelque sorte, vous
savez, proposition de contact physique
et vous savez, ce qui était remarquable, c'est qu'elle a
dit que vous savez qu'elle était jeune, elle avait
peur mais elle est allée le dire à son petit ami
à l'époque qui se trouve être Brad Pitt
et il a confronté Harvey a dit  tu sais,
ne la touche pas,
tu sais et et et Brad Pitt, tu sais,
a maintenant confirmé ce récit par l'intermédiaire d'un
représentant
[Musique],
penses-tu qu'il est un symbole, tu connais, de
l'oppression du pouvoir plus que tout ce que
nous avons tous vécu, donc c'est un
visage collectif de l'homme des cauchemars, c'est
vrai, la machine à complicité est celui que je
juge encore plus que lui
parce qu'il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas dans son
cerveau quelle est leur excuse mais il n'a pas été
protégé uniquement par Hollywood Hollywood l'a
déifié, il était leur chef de secte et
Je saurais que j'ai grandi dans un Je sais comment
ça se passe
[Musique]
croyez-vous que toutes ces femmes
mentent croyez-vous qu'elles mentent, commencez
merci beaucoup, avez-vous honte des
messages pour les femmes
[Applaudissements]
m.  Weinstein n'a pas inventé le casting
couch à Hollywood et dans la mesure
où il y a un mauvais comportement
dans cette industrie, ce n'est pas de cela qu'il s'agit. Le
mauvais comportement n'est pas jugé dans
cette affaire, c'est seulement si vous avez intentionnellement
commis un acte criminel et que M.
Weinstein nie vigoureusement que
[la musique]
aujourd'hui soit véritablement un moment historique pour les
survivants de viols et d'agressions sexuelles dans la
mesure où le public se rend compte que les hommes, même
un homme aussi puissant et célèbre que
Weinstein, seront tenus responsables de
leurs abus envers les femmes.
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant nous pouvons tourner notre attention vers le
prochain procès ici à Los Angeles, nous avons l'
opportunité de tirer parti de cet élan,
ce verdict n'est pas tout mais il est
important